το μόνο επάγγελμα που απέκλια από την αρχή ήταν τα γίνο εκπαιδευτικώς και ο λόγος
ήταν τούτος δεν ήθελα ν ακολουθήσω διαφορία το γονιωμό κι στοχ του οργανισμού αλλά και
ειδική σας προσωπικά για τα επόμενα χρόνια για τη συ είναι η δημιουργεία κουλτούρας επιτυχίας
μενούμε πίσως α χώρα γιατί έχουμε ακόμα δημόσιο το οποίον δεν είναι τόσο πελάτο κεντρικόν
όσο θα πρέπε να είνι το αντριά νι ο κλαίος το περάσε από τον μιλλον
ποτε να σχολεθείμε την πολιτικήαλλάζεικαι τερικί τα υτότητα αλλά δεν άλλάζει απλώσικώνα γι αυτό το
ένα μεσε ένα το υποστηρίζουμε με τις υπηρεσίες μας με τι συμπεριφορά μας προς τους
πελάτες όλα αυτά χτίζου το οικοδόμημα που λέγει τη ησίδα τουτιλες ποςπετησίτα στις τηλεπικοινωνίες έχει
διασφαλήσει τα τελευταία χρόνια ότι η κύπρος δεν είναι μέσως ώρος είναι λί είναι πρώτη
η πρόκληση είναι να μείνουμε ιγέτεκιλες και φίλει άλλο αντεναλλά ευπότκασημερα μαζί σα ένας διαφρατικός
καλεσμένος σήμερα θα μιλήσουμε για τη λεπικοινωνίες και όχι μόνο ο σιοτισσείτα ο κύριος αντρέας
νεοκλαίος είναι μαζί μας και νεο κλαος σα χαιετό και ευχαριστώ πο αποδεκθικά την πρόσκληση
μου ευχαριστό κεερό είναι μια πολύ ρα ευκαιρία για να κάνουμε μια ευχαριστην κουβέντανελπίςποιος να
ξεκινήσουμε τη νερόση που κάνωςσε ως καλεσμένος ποιος είναι ο αντρέας νεοκλαος ο αντρέας είνα
ένας άνθρωπος οποίος έχει ξεκινήσει όπως έχουμε ξεκινήσει όλι από μιαβασική πειδικίνη λιγία κυπριακή τιτις
δεκαϊδείας του ευδομήντα και του ογοδόντα χωρίς πολλά από τα πράγματα τα οποία θεωρούν όλι
δεδομένα